one thing that I find really difficult
to share but I know that once I whether
it's a bachelorette or whether it's
meeting the love of my life once I know
it's for real I won't be able to shut up
about it hi virtually I know that you're
in Australia how are you right now um
I'm doing okay it's I think like
everybody going a little bit stir-crazy
and just trying to figure out a way to
cope with all of the madness I'm
definitely grateful to be near family
right now but I'm me but not me I'm
trying to not go actually to see them
just in case I'm putting them at risk
and I don't and I'm not aware of it so
I'm grateful that I'm in the country in
case anything goes wrong with them and
I'm not a 17 hour flight away great are
you alone then in Australia like at your
own place yes gosh what are you doing
kind of like yeah what are you doing to
pass the time are you lots of notes like
doing some live dance classes in life
cardio dance workouts which has been a
lot of fun for me and actually just
trying to now build more of that content
so I can have some great stuff to give
people while everyone's left at home
trying to design more workouts and more
ways of doing things and even cool
though fun dance classes that I can put
together for people at home because I
think this is gonna be the new normal
for a little while which is daunting
so anything I can do to help me pass the
time and help everyone else that's kind
of the goal right now you know I feel
like you are kind of ahead of the curve
on doing these virtual classes how has
that been for you I mean how do you seem
kind of a surge in people watching and
wanting to take these classes how's that
been for you yeah certainly um my dance
cardio series online has had a massive
surge of people now looking for
something they can do to stay fit and
healthy at home and dance is a beautiful
way to do that and also it's just some
fun to have with the people in your
house too and so I've seen a lot of
people reaching out and buying those and
now asking for more because
of course everyone's home all day every
day we're getting through them very
quickly and I feel that demand for more
content and I love the people are loving
it so I'm just trying to figure out how
I can shoot things in my own heart and
you're the perfect instructor for this I
mean you're so positive you're so
diligent you're so creative you're so
good
is this really giving you more time to
figure out what your future kind of
looks like in in sort of like a silver
lining type of way yeah if there is a
silver lining to all of this on a
personal level I'm not the kind of human
that slows down I've always got
something I'm on to the next thing I'm a
hustling and going at all times and it's
forced me to sit still and think about
okay what am i building where is it
going how's it going and what are some
things that I haven't thought about and
I haven't put as much energy into that
dance how did that work home workout
home series for a little while and it's
it's brought back the passion for it in
all of us because there's such a need
for it and I've even been talking to my
network out here at channel 10 and
Warner about what can we do to create
something like that for people at home
every day every morning and so that's
another conversation to life might be
about to take a bit of a turn for me who
knows I don't know everything is kind of
upside down and it's wild but exciting
yeah there's a lot of uncertainty right
now what are things like in Australia I
feel like I watched the news out here
and I know what's going on in the US
what is it like there we always
certainly don't have as many cases as
you guys have but we also don't have the
population that America does and so you
know naturally our cases are a lot lower
but I would say that we jumped on top of
putting in the restrictions and the lock
downs a lot sooner and thankfully
because of that hasn't spread as badly
as it could I think we've only reached
around 30 deaths that was as of
yesterday and around five and a half
thousand cases across the nation so for
it's hopeful that we can get on top of
this a lot quicker when I watch the news
of what's happening back home in the
States because America is my home it
breaks my heart because I'm hearing
about these numbers of possible
fatalities and it's really really
heartbreaking to know that I'm not there
to be with my friends at the same time
and and just a part of it so I send out
love to everyone every day are you in
touch with a lot of your friends and the
dancing family right now I know I talked
to Cheryl on Friday and she seemed to be
in good spirits as good as like her and
Matt could be but are you in touch with
all of them and I am as much as I can be
we do FaceTime calls all the time I was
on the facetiming with Emma Slater and
such yesterday texting with Peter the
measurer this morning I've got you know
house that house party app fantastic and
do what you can
if anything this situation forces us to
communicate more you know we in this odd
way we we have been spending so much
time on our phones for the last decade
right our faces in our phone and losing
that actual one-on-one physical
interaction with people well now we're
kind of forced into having to learn how
to interact more with our phones and and
I think things like house party and
FaceTime and people having more
conversation you know that's social more
conversation and I think that's probably
a really good thing too
but it's it's been nice to have that
opportunity to be able to connect with
my friends back home because I've been
away since January didn't expect to be
away this long yeah how many ones is
that that's a couple of months yeah
we're heading on four months now and
it'll probably be six months until I can
hopefully I can come back in June but
who knows at this point if the flight
bans will stick and the lockdowns will
stick and we have to be sure that this
is this has gone away but I mean I'm
certainly not getting on a 17 hour plane
ride I know I I know that you were I
guess in talks you had told me that you
were in talks to possibly be the bad
Clarett in Australia is that still
happening
no the Bachelorette has been postponed
100% as a thing and the bachelor season
that was mid filming has been postponed
and put on hold
we've had to for safety reasons I mean
you just can't take that risk
our season of Dancing with the Stars
here we brought forward our finale by
one week and thankfully we were so far
along in the season we could give a
genuine and to the season and a real
winner and I'm grateful for that but all
of the other exciting opportunities that
may have been possible have now been put
on hold until further notice and I mean
there's no amount of money you could pay
me to be locked in a house with you know
25 of April right now absolutely I
totally get that
is that something then that you would
revisit in the future like could you
still be the Bachelorette maybe next
year well I'm not magically mating my
life pot that was locked up in my house
on my cart pretty hard to raise right
yes it's still a conversation I navigate
the me yes or no though certainly
leaning more towards the guests side of
it and then all that this happens so
either I'm gonna listen to the universe
and be like well maybe that's a sign
that I don't need to or if it comes back
around again and and I'm still single
and it's still an opportunity then yeah
then probably I mean you would I already
told you this but you would be a
phenomenal Bachelorette like you know
what you want
you're a perfect catch like you're
talented and they're genuine this is
what the world needs
what about Dancing with the Stars
because when I talked to Cheryl she said
they don't know what's gonna happen
she's hoping for the fall season but
also like are they gonna have to figure
out some sort of way to do this
virtually are you have you been into all
the crews you turn to the show
there is gosh I don't know how you do
Dancing with the Stars virtually that is
an incredible question where there's a
will there's a way
and we can figure it out
as far as I know dancing is is plenty of
going ahead with their fall season but
these things change week to week right
now I certainly hope that they there is
a way to figure it out because I think
the world needs that kind of fun
carefree loving show that is just about
seeing people do good and overcoming
adversity and dancing you know which
brings everybody joy so I hope that that
there is an opportunity to put that show
on if there isn't if we can't do it in
the form that it exists in I am sure the
creative team over there and the one who
like producing team will figure out how
to make it work in fitting with all the
guidelines but that's also what's crazy
this is like the new normal for awhile
and we don't want to lose these shows
for 12 months while the planet recovers
and we make sure that we're free of this
code that 19 so somehow we're gonna
figure out a way how to keep put you
know the show must go on and I think if
anyone can figure it out it's today so
it's does tape the show will you be back
I would love to be I certainly miss it
and I and now sort of being away I miss
all my friends I haven't seen it so long
and I would love to be that it hasn't
been a conversation they haven't asked
me yet I'm sure they've got a lot more
things to worry about on whether I'm
gonna be coming back or not really and
it's still early so we'll see but you
know as I've said before I have so much
love for them and and especially my my
fam that that are competing on the show
too and I'd love to be there but if I
can't be on the show and I can be in the
audience then I absolutely will be in
the audience cheering yeah that's why
you're the best you're such like a ray
of sunshine and you're so supportive of
other people I know you also have always
like all these other types of projects
in the works like you choreograph for
other shows and you yes me about these
plates are how is this copán 19
situation affecting all of that kind of
work I mean it's really really hot
because all of that kind of work
involves performance and people and
physical touch and multiple people in a
room
these things that we cannot do right now
you know you can't walk around in groups
with more than two people outside here
in the stress it's like how do i how do
we create these things Esther is still
an option we are still trying to get to
Broadway for hopefully 2021 it's getting
that funding to take us to Broadway she
takes a lot of millions to get to them
you know and it it's a long road but we
are still all in on that one and for now
the direction has changed a little bit
going back to the workouts and the what
can I create the people that they can do
at home in their living room and so the
conversation is shifted a little bit
from where it was with the other
projects and new ones are arising so I'm
very very grateful for that to be
evolving with the times and to have
people that still want to create things
with me and hopefully it will see I'll
see this opportunity you know come to
life of being able to help people at
home whether that is learning how to
dance with various takes it staying
motivated st. focus because it's really
really hard at a time like this losing
motivation and focus is a really big
thing and if I can help with that in any
way then I am so down yeah
changing gears just a little bit I feel
like we are in Hollywood and there's
such an emphasis on exterior and the
hair and the nails and the skin and all
that kind of stuff not having access to
go and kind of take care of those things
are you enjoying it a little bit this is
the first time I've put on makeup in
like three weeks I grew an eyebrow today
I must forgotten how to do it
it's actually been really nice to not
have to you know book the nail
appointment and and worry about all
these things important suffocating
makeup on my skin and just let
everything feel natural and breathe for
a while but certainly when I was putting
on makeup this morning I was like
there's that face that I'm that I'm used
to
yeah but you know it's I think it's we
got to embrace that moment too we get so
caught up in there
the hair and the nails and the makeup
and the lashes and to look right the
image and this is the time to just fall
in love with us as we are in our natural
and real form and take care of ourselves
you know it's beauty on the inside at
this point to make sure everyone is
taking their supplements and stay
healthy make sure that everyone is you
know even it staying focused and setting
a schedule in your day in your days at
home set when you wake up set when you
have coffee set when you workout set
when you get to go on Instagram you know
if you give yourself a schedule it all
helps us feel healthy stay healthy and
stay focused and motivated yeah I also
know that you have a YouTube channel now
I do have been sort of building that and
creating content for that and sharing
more of yourself through a completely
new platform and figuring out more time
to really develop that for yourself
during its yeah I'm actually in the
middle of putting together a list of new
content to film while here at home all
of the videos that I had pre shot and
edited have now been released and it's
time for me to do more and it seems that
what people want from me is like
skincare regimes and oddly makeup
tutorials which is very interesting I
just put up my first makeup tutorial
ever which was I would call it's like
just a smidge of a fail but it was just
me being a hot mess the whole time
trying to figure it out but so much love
and props to the people that do these on
YouTube all the time but being a
creative I'm certainly loving figuring
it out and having fun and getting to
share that part of me anything that you
are hesitant to share now that you are
putting more of yourself out there the
only thing that I've ever been really
private about is my dating life well in
like mostly like recent years I used to
share everything up until I was that 30
in my last long-term relationship ended
and because that's the only thing where
it's like it's hard even in your own
circle of family and friends you want to
have your own opinion no everyone else's
opinion you don't to be overly
influenced by what other people think of
the decisions of the choice
is that your banking and so that's
something that I've kept pretty private
for a while and so that's why this whole
decision with the Bachelorette is a
really really big deal for me because
that's the one thing that I've kept
pretty much private I am down the talk
about you know the things growing up and
the environmental or the mummy daddy
issues that we all have or the acne or
the you know all the things that we go
through and it is learning how to become
a whole human just the one thing that I
find really difficult to share but I
know that once I whether it's the
Bachelorette or whether it's meeting the
love of my life once I know it's for
real I won't be able to shut up about it
it's just that like yeah process of
finding and you know ii mean i think you
hit the nail on the head because no one
likes to talk about something when
they're unsure or like uncertain about
something right it's not until you feel
like you're in a comfortable position
with this significant other or with
someone that you even want to talk about
it so i for sure understand you on that
but if you do the Bachelorette you are
gonna get other words of question nobody
just questions it's like opinions are
your dancing castmates wanting you to do
it oh yeah yeah absolutely they're old
like a mop Peter Lindsey everybody is
like do it do it do it do the cheering
for cuz of course the huge fans of the
show too and they think that I am crazy
to even just like considering whether I
would or wouldn't they think it's a
solid yes uh and you know there's a lot
of family members that feel the same way
too but then there's also some family
members that are like do you want to do
that are you sure so but again this is
only my decision to make and it's it's
nothing against the show I think the
show is fantastic it's just that one
part of my life that I've kept pretty
private do I want to put the biggest
microscope of all time on it
[Music]